[Music]
during a commencement speech in Texas
Saturday former New York City Mayor
Michael Bloomberg said Americans face an
epidemic of dishonesty that's worse than
Torah the greatest threat to American
democracy isn't communism or jihadism or
any other external force or foreign
power it is our own willingness to
tolerate dishonesty in service a party
and in pursuit of power my mic fell off
so blue methinks words from Trump are
deadlier than deeds from a terrorist
which leads one to ask when blue Berg
was mayor of New York City what do you
think his number-one concern was fibs or
terror do you think he woke up every
morning and thought my god I hope
someone's not lying on their tax returns
no instead he was focused on terror the
number one threat to New York City and
America was and still is terrorism not
whether Trump exaggerated tsubame copán
for the wall point is for blew me to
express his own gripes like climate
change or smoking or gun control first
he had to keep the city safe so he could
have the luxury of griping so now in a
speech when he reorders our concerns
just to draft jab Donald Trump he's
committing the very sin he derives he's
falsifying facts for the only way one
can complain about partisanship being
worse than communism or jihadism is to
diminish the piles of bodies caused by
both but all of this could be due to one
truth right now Trump may make history
with the Koreas and bloomie he's whining
about fake news out of college that's
gotta hurt so Jessie do you think this
was just some kind of hyperbole you do
in a speech he can't really mean that
this is worse than terror or or a
communism no I mean Ally didn't fly into
a building and kill 3,000 people but I
am available as we're talking about to
do commencements if anybody's interested
I'd think I'd look good in the tassel
but that was a nice outfit that was I
like the yellow he looked like a waiter
at the medieval restaurants no what do
they call medieval times and evil times
have you been there recently I eat there
every night Atkins friendly
I love the line about how do you know
when a politician is lying his lips are
moving I think all politicians lie I
would rather have a politician lie
though about I would have rather have a
politician lie about sex or about a
crowd sighs that about not being able to
keep your health care or a terrorist
attack there's white lies and then
there's whoppers and that's fine this
was clearly a shot at Trump and the
people in the press that don't hold him
accountable but I think the fake news
puts out maybe the same amount of junk
as President Trump does if not more I
mean I have the fake news media Awards
right here one and I'm happy to recite
them that's fine at the same at the same
time I don't think Trump's a liar I just
think he's a boaster yeah from Queens
real estate tycoon is the biggest it's
the best it's most expensive and a lot
of people consider those opinions lies
they'll fact check his opinion he'll say
I'm the best looking president there
ever is and then the Pinocchio people
fact-check that yeah it's like a car
salesman saying like the little old lady
just drove this car to church on
weekends and everybody's winking it's a
sale it's all right one should Bloomberg
apologize to America for what he just
did
right now you have to start with the
apology every single American has to go
on one coast Trump
should apologize I mean you know what's
interesting you said this is like so
shocking you should be surprised how
many people in the intelligence
community I think back to Leon Panetta I
think of John Brennan etc right people
who say it is the biggest threat to us
as a nation this kind of divide because
it's just what the Russians want we
can't decide anything everything is a
huge argument last week I wrote a
comment said you know when you look at
what went on in terms of the decision to
pull the United States away from the
Iran deal the president with his
boastfulness however you want to
describe it I think it's persuasive to a
lot of people because there's partisan
sport they say oh the Iran deal has been
violated it was a weak deal terrible
deal and yet the fact is that the deal
was never violated
the fact is that people say this was
keeping Iran from having nukes but now
it suddenly said well maybe it was a bad
day maybe it's just a partisan fight
maybe he doesn't like Obama
baby doesn't like John care and we lose
sight of the truth we can't even get
anything done alright so that no want is
deflected Kimberly to an entirely
different topic totally different
Bluebird is mad that he didn't run for
president oh yeah that's what it is he's
mad that he didn't run for president
he's mad that President Trump has
honored his campaign promises and is
checking off wins on the board anyone
who loves this country should be happy
that we're moving towards these anyone
should be happy that the economy is
doing better anyone should be happy that
their more jobs here in America and that
minorities are feeling better about
what's happening in this country there's
so many accomplishments and things and
as it relates to national security and
foreign policy he has completely
completely changed the dynamic this is a
new style of politics and engaging to
create effective result why not if you
keep doing the same thing and you end up
at the end result why not try a
different way or a different path to be
able to achieve these ends also
president Trump is using social media
and Twitter to be able to communicate so
there is transparency there versus
someone regurgitating going through it
and then putting something out I don't
think there's a downside to that because
every person then can be the individual
consumer and determine what you think of
it and versus someone telling you what
to think I think there's a tremendous
downside to constant line from the man
is the president the leader of our
country and people can't trust okay
we're never gonna solve this if you're
lying is he boasting Dana clean it up
for us I think that every commencement
speech would be more successful if it
made no news yes are you supposed to be
about the students and the in generation
for for them to go out into the world to
celebrate the fact that they're getting
through college right and I have a
chance to go and make their mark on the
world and worrying about fake news is
probably not the highest priority I want
to do a commencement address for an
online college would that be great just
cynics universe Phoenix University would
be amazing
here are their top choice you know it